ha there's it so hello everybody I'm
mark good to see you
yeah all right guys I'm Tim hi I'm Ty
nice to meet you hello my name is Doyle
nice to meet you I'm Utah I'm Johnny
so congratulations on a highway to
heaven I mean I listened to it and I
heard a popular highway in Los Angeles
and I was like okay 101 I know that but
I want to know what's the inspiration
behind the song oh if you wanted to
really deliver our free-spirited energy
oh through this one cuz you've never
really had an energy like this ever
before and so the highway to having we
wanted to encourage our fans to cannot
forget their stresses and through our
music just enjoy and I'll go to the
highway to heaven with this yeah
you also will shot an amazing music
video for two I mean it looked like a
lot of fun what do you guys remember
about making a music video for this oh
yes somebody's already got Georgia coda
no don't go home don't take it home
we'll have a cool thing torn and there
is a creamy sauces right - mr. Walker he
says it was actually our first time
filming inside a desert right so it was
really hot but he said but in the end it
came out really good and that's what
that's good yeah I was gonna say they're
sweating with all the dancing - and
there's a lot of wind blowing and they
had like like our white shirts on right
pretty cool and also we filmed all real
101 livered yeah oh yeah the highway way
yes very good experience
yeah well it's such a Bop and I'm
putting it on heavy rotation on my
playlist
oh yeah I really am thank you yeah
absolutely I mean you guys heard me
singing it before oh oh yeah
oh yeah yeah we'll take the highway to
heaven and I can't wait to love you all
alone oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah see it
now part of the group
yeah I'm going on tour with you okay of
course the question I think that all
your fans want to know is when can they
expect some more new music well I think
we're always working on new music so oh
when it'll come out we can't really say
cuz it a little bit of a secret but you
know oh we're getting ready you are so
they can always you know have their
hearts a little ready you know yeah oh
yeah when it does though it'll be good
we already know that though don't we we
already know that you guys wrapped up
the US leg of your first world tour
earlier this year what was that
experience like for you guys to travel
around the United States reppin bus oh
yeah what's that
well we had a we had a tour bus right
and like we had like our picture like
huge picture on it and we kind of went
around in that tour bus and it was a
different feeling going from city to
city in that bus it felt like you know
like like a like a movie that's the
Rockstar life yeah yeah oh he says
there's no time that can like beat that
it was in an unforgettable very special
yeah well speaking of special
experiences you guys just performed at
the Macy's Thanksgiving Day that is a
huge deal in America without a huge deal
for you guys did you feel the energy
yeah yeah there were a lot of people
like outside just waving anything really
yeah have you been giving and everybody
was really like a lot of smiles the big
floats right yeah Jimmy and the black ID
it was all a good Thanksgiving
experience kind of cool right that's
amazing you guys I want to talk about
your EP we are super human cuz listening
to it really does sound like a blend of
all kinds of diffe
genres it's hard to pinpoint one you
know so how would you guys say your
music compares to other mainstream
artists I would like to say oh and I
want people to know entity 27 as a group
who can really reach out to a lot of
donors and I think that's our main core
purpose we always have diversity as our
main trade so that also comes into our
music and ourselves as well we're from
different cultures and we all like
different things and that all goes out
and that's all expressed through music
and so um like what you said we can't
really pinpoint to one genre we like to
go out in a variety of ways yeah and I'm
sure for you guys as artists it's more
fun to experiment write different types
of music I feel like that's what our
fans really find interesting and people
who listen to kpop as well so that's
what's really different about it how
does it feel for you guys starting out
to now be part of this huge wave of
success for k-pop artists I am actually
very very like happy to be a part of it
and all for what I'm doing I'm so in a
way proud I'm in and as much as we're
proud and um we feel a responsibility of
showing more of kpop and you know like
there's never been a time like this for
kpop for it to go so widely lake spread
so um we're very happy and we just want
to take this opportunity and really I'm
sure what we've got and what um what the
culture of kpop is the music business is
crazy your journey has been really crazy
how I mean and you hear this all the
time not just with k-pop artists but all
kinds of bands you know juggling travel
the busy schedules different
personalities how do you guys deal with
all that teamwork maybe because we're
always traveling with the same people I
think it's important how we can
sometimes just maybe that kind of lean
on one another like like because we eat
together we like sleep neat like we're
in the same house together and I think
that just really uh that kind of shows
in our performances like in like as well
yeah yeah how would you guys say you
bonded like how have you guys gotten
close
how have you what have you learned about
each other I think to say that also
comes from what we just talked about
late having to experience all the bad
the good times or all the times together
just bonded us in the very close way
like on to be with each other like 24/7
like seven days weekly I think we're
pretty all the time yeah we're pretty
much family yeah yeah all the time right
yeah we're in a way VCR fat we see each
other more than our family so yeah we
are family obviously you guys are bonded
but you also have such a deep connection
with your fans out there so like what
message you have for all those NCT one
to seven fans out there who analyze you
watch your videos and listen to your
music
I wish burn my little boy whatever
wouldn't answer is women der bundeswehr
okay bunny cousins Aguilar Christ in the
mortis communist of the consider in
Denver cemetery which cool oh this is
mere Tanika so even when it she would
say to okay so yeah he feels like the
reason we're able to travel all around
the world is because of our fans are and
citizens and you just want to really
take this time to things them and to let
them know that it's because of you guys
that we're here you guys are energy
always thankful we love you yeah well
before I let you go I want to hit you
with a couple of rapid-fire questions
right come at me a little bit
who'd you guys say are your biggest
musical inspirations and then Muse for
me it'd have to be Usher
okay that's your baby alright if you
weren't artist what would you be doing
for a career I think I'd be an author
that was my old dream firefighters yeah
fire
[Music]
oh just a rich guy what do you guys like
to do in your free time
and drinking coffee coffee you can
coffee bean coffee I'm working out
[Music]